E aí galerinha que assiste meu canal
hoje eu vou mostrar para vocês Adivinha
o quê Hahaha essa pousadinha aqui em
Icaraí já montada Pousada café Zapata
esse aqui é o Marcão fundador e
proprietário olha aí ó
vou mostrar tudo direitinho vamos
mostrar ela desde a entrada para ele ver
mas qual era veterinário em Brasília e
aí veio faz quanto tempo 14 anos já aí
meu filho eu conheci aqui nós ficamos
brother e eu virei um visitante depois
virei um investidor um racionista
aqui é a frente ó
bonitinha se chama café Zapata a gente
gosta muito de animais e Zapata era o
nome da primeira cachorrinha dele que eu
tinha aquela moral bang bang
esse lado aqui também é Nossa a gente
vai construir não posso falar ainda
porque nós estamos criando ainda né
bonito barquinha
aí Aqui um restaurante
aqui para você ficar de buenas aqui tem
um restaurante
agora são que horas são agora Amaral
agora são 3:26 restaurante tá fechado
como é que é as especificações aqui tu
falou dos chefes e o
chefe
premiado aqui no Ceará
meu filho você pode vir aqui não não é
ele que é o chefe né que tem o chefe
premiado aqui de Ceará é uma janta
sensacional café da manhã sensacional
aqui todo mundo
álcool gel máscara cuidadinho
aqui nós já entramos dentro da Pousada
meu quarto eu tô hoje é o quarto Tarzan
que é esse ali em cima tem um quarto
aqui embaixo Mas Sobe aqui
ai tem um barquinho aí só mais um
pouquinho o quartinho que eu estou hoje
que tem uma Redinha
e é um barquinho é muito massa
banheirinha tudo simples aqui é o lugar
de enfim trouxe protetor
[Música]
olha aqui é que eu mostrei lá de cima
para vocês
aqui a gente vai construir uma parada
indo um negócio bem ih pai para
ai pai para balcão para quando a gente
vem para cá geralmente fica só nós aqui
a gente fecha para nós não é que ele te
escolhe já para vir quando já tá meio
que sem ninguém e aí dá uma aquida aqui
tá os meninos
tem quarto já aí tu quer dormir na cama
e na rede
que a cabeça dele fica na cama e o corpo
mas só que eu vou macrolar mais tarde eu
preciso de dormir mas você tem um quarto
vida
mas não dá um de vocês
está convidado para dormir comigo na
suíte da praia
Essa pousada aqui tem uma extensãozinha
né que são dois bangalôzinho lá na beira
da praia aí um de vocês vai ser O
Felizardo
[Música]
eu não sei se ele pode porque tipo é eu
tenho que dormir entendeu não você pode
talvez acordar a vizinha assim inteira
né
Tem gente que precisa dormir até os
próprios beijos preciso dormir para ser
pescados no outro dia se não chegou o
celular aonde eu
que fica aí de Amontada
200 km de Fortaleza 100 km do aeroporto
de Jeri ele tá querendo levar as bikes
do carro para para ali para o
bangalôzinho para vocês verem como ela
também tem um na praia ai Padre viu
danilinho aí Danilo foi embora
vamos nessa passei aqui aí gostou de ter
visto a pousadinha aqui no Ceará deixa
eu clicar em gostei não clica em gostei
Comenta aí embaixo qual lugar você ainda
não conheceu do Nordeste Você tem
vontade de conhecer engraçado
você pensa que é pesado
agora é hora de mostrar aqui entendeu
[Aplausos]
ele comeu um peixe ali no Zé agora ficou
embargado
três dias que ele tá aí embarcado vai
vai embora
Eu duvido tu dar um grau de costas
Olha o tamanho do pneu da bike do Amaral
quanto é que tá o passeio patrão
e a galera acha que não tem praia quando
tem chuva tá aí
agora não tem
isso é um tipo de treinamento
já vai clicando em gostei aí hein eu Sei
Empinar
[Música]
olha aqui galera
parece causas naturais né
Acho que não né
meus amigos Estamos dando uma voltinha
de bike na chuva a zeólicas e no mar vem
com a gente não esquece de deixar o seu
joinha você já conheceu Pousada já está
conhecendo praia mais coisa pode botar
aí que que vocês querem comenta aí ah
jeru a gente não conhece a praia a gente
pode trazer ele para conhecer a praia é
só você dizer comente aí embaixo curta
compartilha vamos nessa com a gente vou
dar o play hein na minha música
Mas se a noite tremendo bem caindo
descendo você não precisa chorar
deixa que eu te ensino a voar eu falo
com grande divide comigo eu juro que eu
te ajudo aqui então deixa eu te ensinar
vai ficar doido gata
olha como é que eu tô
é o preço que se paga por via bike né
deu prego deu prego
Você tá muito linda olha esse quadro
Olha isso
praticamente
passa a mão nela pro lado assim olha
coisas de regime
porque tá chovendo não dá para confiar
em você
olha aí que bonito a água direto do pau
dá um close aqui na cara né porque você
não nesse momento
tá você pode pegar diária de meio-dia
até às 6:00 né
é mais indicado para para duas pessoas
mas como sempre brasileiro gosta de
Inovar muitas vezes ele é lugar para 16
17 até 20 25 pessoas né
irado parece de velho Oeste né assim
também lembro um pouco uma colorida é aí
já já fica mais legais tá irada essa tá
irada É porque ela tá meio antiga assim
aí não dá aquele tanto que ele arde
velho oeste
foi lá nos três últimos prints